hallo mein name ist nun kann endlich
will kommen heute zu einem neuen video
spiele heute ein spiel und dieses spiel
heißt live
the game
play also klar ist nicht mehr der
spielername place wenn man drauf dass
man dieses spiel beinhaltet das leben
und zwar von der geburt an über die
kindlichkeit was ist eine kindlichkeit
deswegen haltet auf jeden fall alle
möglichen schritte des lebens und alle
möglichen wandlungen und keine ahnung
was also ich würde anbieten einfach mal
direkt auf play umsehen schon get bohren
müssen jetzt wenn das hier in der mitte
ist immer so ein bisschen drauf drücken
so dass das
schon verloren auf youtube put you up
for auction everton konnte gern alles
klar
leute das war's dann jedoch vom video
ich wurde anscheinend zur adoption frei
einfach auf try again dh es geht wollen
und immer wenn es da drin ist muss ich
mich raus quetscht wo ich bin darin drin
umgekehrt muss ich hier hier hier hier
hier hier hier hier hier hier hier hier
denn noch ein bisschen weiter reden und
jetzt bin ich schon ein kind das heißt
jetzt steht hier ist da die und ich muss
doch wie soll man das denn so schnell
schaffen
judith masters rogers school teddys oder
wenn ihr kleid vor job flipping
berghäuser gott also die sagen mir
gerade sich so schlecht in mathe war
dass ich burgerbrater geworden bin das
heißt es geht wieder von vorne los mit
study 17 23 hier also wenn das jetzt
hier richtig ist dann einsplus okay
jetzt kommt die pubertät das heißt ich
muss wahrscheinlich meine pickel
irgendwie ausdrücken war es das ekelhaft
man das ist irgendwie ein
geschicklichkeitsspiel und auch einen
schnelligkeit spiel also ich muss mich
hier gerade echt ein bisschen beeilen
weil die ganze zeit nur sachen irgendwie
auch blogger jetzt habe ich ein date und
muss jetzt irgendwelche richtigen leute
nach rechts zur seite ziehen und
irgendwie why not südbeck
hey
nochmal mit dem date also dass nach
rechts ist nach links das auch noch
links das nach rechts das noch nicht
als wenn ich so ein tintenfisch nach
rechts hier ich kriege wieder auf tragen
das heißt wieder date rechts links links
rechts als auch rechts auch rechtsfähig
habe match jetzt muss ich sport machen
also
beer pong spielen oh gott ich habe durch
unzählige besser unzählige bälle
[Musik]
wir kriegen die bierbaum kriegt man
einfach noch mal auftragen und werfen
jetzt hier alles in die becher rein also
hier hier hier über
der becher ist umgefallen ich will es
jetzt aber wissen also ich muss hier
schon geraden
als wenn es so schwer ist kaffee machen
denn das braucht man immer noch milch
und zucker
jetzt muss ich verheiratet werden und
mich vernünftig anziehen also so so so
und ich bin verheiratet meine damen und
herren jetzt muss sich kinder kriegen
das heißt das heißt jetzt so bleiben
midlife crisis ein paar sekunden später
farc und recht verstehen des shopping
list haben sich das denn jetzt erst die
begründung diesmal ist on your way home
you realize that you forgot bei
everything you look lock your thing
you've ever wonder what could have been
das ist die midlife crisis midlife
crisis im juca travel ticket und
gewichte also so weiter die gewichte und
das travel ticket befindet sich hier das
heißt das haben wir geschafft rentier
drin also ich bin jetzt ein opa und muss
die
babysitter vors tor wo ist auf jeden
fall scheißegal ich denke jedoch dran
steht und ich glaube ich muss die alle
zu der oma bringen irgendwie ich hab die
laufe ich muss die wohl alle immer
irgendwie bei der roma halten also so so
so so nein ich schwöre euch dieses spiel
und diese kinder bringen mich auf die
palme
nein du kreiste ihr bleibt alle hier
schön in der mitte keiner von euch macht
irgendwie war es du bleibst hier do do
do do ist dahin du gehst du gehst dahin
hier so bam bam bam du gehst nicht
versteckt sich zum feuer auch nicht so
steckdose
steffi jetzt muss ich für den
ich weiß nicht ob ihr das gerade seht
aber achtet mal darauf wo ich mit der
maus bin und wie dieses ding da
hinterher platte also ich weiß nicht ob
ich das schaffe wenn schon liegt
wirklich an der website ich will der ist
nicht die schuld geben für meinen nicht
für mein versagen aber das ist noch nur
noch beschließen wie diese teile hier
fliegen oh mein gott ich kann sogar
vielleicht noch schaffen freuen dass den
grünen
[Musik]
ich kann ich machen will tauss stehen
ich habe angst freunde das herz wird
gerade irgendwie rosa hier ist ein ja
ist ein neues spiel afterlife das heißt
meine damen und herren wir haben das
leben gut verstand wir sind
zwischendurch so ca 10 mal irgendwie
verrückt aber das juckt ja nachher kein
ich fand das game eigentlich ganz cool
also es war halt ganz cool für sonnen
video jetzt grade mal so nebenbei also
wenn dann wie ihr euch gefallen hat das
game ein leichter findet jetzt hier oben
ein smiley eingeblendet wenn ihr darauf
könnte meinen kanal kostenlos abonnieren
findet ihr auch meinen shop eingeblendet
wo ihr sommerklamotten und so weiter so
ein scheiß kaufen können und die unten
befindet sich ein anderes video
klickt dann drauf
ey